[Musique]
parmi les six voyants comme on les
appelle plusieurs continuent de vivre au
village
Maria Yvan participent à la vie de la
paroisse Saint-Jacques de Medjugorje et
interviennent régulièrement à la messe
[Musique]
tout commence durant l'été 1981 6
adolescents âgés de 11 à 17 ans quatre
filles et deux garçons affirment voir la
Vierge Marie sur une colline dans le
village ils sont les seuls témoins
visuels de cette manifestation
nous sommes un an après la mort de Tito
10 ans avant le début de la guerre en
Yougoslavie et la Vierge de Medjugorje
se fait appeler la Reine de la Paix
[Musique]
Je vous salue Marie
alors ce jour-là miriana et
Ivanka les deux vont être là en
attendant vidska
et à un moment donné dans l'après-midi
vers 5 heures de l'après-midi le 24 juin
Ivanka
tourne son regard vers la colline et dit
à l'autre mais c'est la Vierge
[Musique]
l'autre fille sa copine c'est à dire
miriana une fille de ville de Sarajevo
elle va dire mes doigts quoi tu parles
quelle vierge
ça se peut pas que la Vierge
les apparaissent
cette nuit-là rare sont ceux qui ont
dormi vraiment
le lendemain le 25 juin 1981 vers 18h
les deux adolescentrent à la colline
avec quatre camarades cette fois tous
les 6 disent voir la Gospa la dame comme
on l'appelle ici
et
[Musique]
Ivan nous avons commencé à voir
l'apparition tous les jours au début
nous avions peur parce que nous savions
pas qui c'était même si dans nos coeurs
nous savions que c'était la Sainte
Vierge la grand-mère de visca a dit
prenez de l'eau bénite aspergez
l'apparition d'Aubigné
de Dieu reste et si tu n'es pas de Dieu
va-t'en et à cet instant la Vierge a
souri et elle a dit qu'elle était la
mère de Dieu et qu'elle était venue ici
parce qu'elle avait trouvé la foi ici
c'est-à-dire que je la vois comme je
vous vois je parle avec elle comme je
parle avec vous et je peux la toucher
aussi
[Musique]
peu à peu la Vierge nous a permis de
l'embrasser à certaines occasions pour
nos anniversaires
en fait quand nous voyons la vierge elle
est toujours vêtue d'une longue robe
grise de long voile blanc
les yeux bleus et se tient debout sur un
nuage et elle a une couronne d'étoile
autour de la tête
c'est-à-dire que nous voyons la Vierge
comme toute autre personne
[Musique]
souvent les enfants interviennent au
début de
l'apparitions
chrétienne il personnalise l'innocence
donc la parole dit par un enfant est
plus crédible qu'une parole émise par un
adulte
c'est l'église locale qui intervient en
acceptant ou refusant la parole des
enfants
donc il est vrai que les enfants sont
importants mais seulement dans la phase
initiale après c'est l'autorité
religieuse qui légitimise ou non cette
vérité vous savez que la pratique
religieuse
durant toute cette période de dictature
communiste a été interdite
mais alors parler des apparitions
c'était impensable pour les autorités
communistes donc ils ont commencé tout
de suite à persécuter les enfants à
persécuter le village et à persécuté les
Franciscains en passant que c'est les
Franciscains qui auraient tout inventé
[Musique]
pour empêcher les apparitions la police
communiste décide de bloquer l'accès à
la colline le curé du village un frère
franciscain invite alors les enfants à
se réfugier dans l'église
désormais leur apparition quotidienne
aura lieu dans la chapelle pendant le
fils du soir vers 18h15
[Musique]
depuis le début des apparitions chaque
matin les pèlerins vont écouter la
voyante Vichy vankovic parmi les voyants
visca est la seule célibataire elle
consacre toutes ses matinées à délivrer
les messages qu'elle dit avoir reçu de
Marie la Vierge lui aurait montré le
purgatoire et les enfers et aurait
demandé à viscade avertir le monde des
dangers que Satan lui fait courir
elle appelle les hommes à se tourner
vers Dieu avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
va parler dans quelques minutes et il
interprète va traduire en français
ça a été difficile de se faufiler ouais
alors on attend un message
[Musique]
principaux que la Vierge nous donne ce
sont la prière
et la paix
commercial la conversion
confessionnelle la confession des dunes
et le jeûne
petit traiteur
de prier à chaque jour le Rosaire
avec Jésus-Christ quand les peuples
suivaient ici c'est la même chose
incroyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puis moi ça me faisait de la peine parce
que j'ai l'impression que Marie soit
elle aussi ça y fait de la peine c'est
pour ça qu'elle veut elle veut qu'on
considère ce qu'on vit en amour qu'on
vive dans la paix donc pour que on se
bouscule puis c'est les voyelles bon ils
ont un don ils ont des grands spéciales
mais ça reste des êtres humains faut pas
en faire des idoles
vraiment elle ne vit pas pour elle moi
je la considère très très haut dans la
santé
non seulement une personne totalement
donnée qui se donne totalement mais une
personne qui a eu aussi des épreuves de
souffrance multiples n'aime pas les dire
mais enfin il y en a qu'on devine enfin
ce qu'on appelle une âme victime j'aime
pas beaucoup ce terme
bizarre et dramatique mais il y a des
gens qui comme le cric fin comme le
Christ a souffert la passion il nous a
sauvé en passant par la passion il y a
des gens qui sont appelés à subir les
mêmes épreuves
et pour moi c'est le cas de disque
[Musique]
l'imposition des mains par les voyants
c'est une caricature quand même de la
grande tradition chrétienne celui qui
impose les mains d'abord c'est l'évêque
ce ne sont pas les voyants
il y a
et puis même si le sacerdo c'est qu'elle
soit mal utilisé le l'objectif de
l'ordination avec le geste de
l'imposition des mains c'est quand même
envoyé pour diffuser la Bonne Nouvelle
du salut
tandis que là
j'avoue que je ne vois pas ce que peut
signifier
cette ce geste des mains par les voyants
c'est parce que les gens l'exigent vous
savez les gens savent que j'ai été
malade ils savent à quel point j'ai
souffert et ils ont l'impression que si
je leur ai posé main ils vont sentir
mieux alors si quelqu'un me demande de
lui imposer les mains je ne vais pas
dire que je ne peux pas le faire c'est
normal de le faire au nom de la vierge
mais moi je n'ai pas le pouvoir de faire
des miracles en revanche Dieu lui fait
des miracles et il utilise les gens
parfois pour faire ses miracles
[Musique]
on a été le couple ensemble la voix va
nous imposer les meilleurs restants Je
vous salue Marie
on a communiqué avec celle-ci c'est
intérieurement c'est
il y a pas plus belle grasse que ça
c'est des forces qui fait que quand on
arrive dans la ville après dans le
public les gens nous regardent et puis
voit le sourire pratiquement le sourire
de Marie c'est ce que de Dieu veut
[Musique]
parmi les six voyons trois d'entre eux
continuent chaque jour de voir la Vierge
le phénomène a lieu à domicile comme ici
chez Maria
cette jeune femme mère de trois enfants
a aménagé chez elle cette petite
chapelle pour accueillir les pèlerins
d'après Maria c'est à 18h40 précise que
Marie lui apparaît
elle restera dans cette position pendant
plus de 3 minutes
en 1985 et 1998 deux équipes de
chercheurs catholiques françaises et
italiens ont étudié scientifiquement le
déclenchement des apparitions chez les
voyants de Medjugorje
une première mondiale en matière de
recherche psycho physiologique sur des
voyants ils ont posé des électrons
céphalogrammes ils ont analysé leur
sensibilité à la douleur leur rythme de
respiration leur fréquence cardiaque les
scientifiques en ont conclu qu'au moment
précis du début de l'apparition les
voyants entrent effectivement dans un
état modifié de conscience qu'on appelle
l'extase
si un hypnose
que ce soit en hypnose ou en extase si
nous piquons de sujet il ne répond plus
à la stimulation externe
idem si nous lui envoyons un son très
fort dans l'oreille ou bien un faisceau
de lumière intense dans les yeux c'est
cela le passage aux États modifié de la
conscience
les sujets ne répondent plus aux
stimulus externes et aucune lésion ne se
produit par exemple les yeux qui sont
exposés à une lumière intense pendant
l'extase ne présente pas de lésions au
contraire de quelqu'un qui regarderait
le soleil alors qu'il est en état de
veille normal
physiquement quelqu'un qui est en extase
ressemble à quelqu'un qui n'est pas en
extase à ceux-ci près que si on le
touche a priori la moindre réaction les
yeux sont homme généralement fixes mais
quelquefois les yeux peuvent battre et
dans d'autres cas on a remarqué que les
yeux pouvaient au contraire ne pas s'y
les pendant des périodes extraordinaires
qui sera absolument impossible à tenir
pour quelqu'un qui sera en état normal
[Musique]
même si les voyants sont en extase s'ils
sont mentalement ailleurs la science ne
peut pas prouver la réalité de
l'apparition ni la présence de Marie
toutefois une chose est sûre parmi les
six voyants de Medjugorje il y a au
moins un simulateur qui ne voit rien ni
Vierge Marie ni même représentation
mentale de celle-ci mais qui copie les
autres depuis le début
le secret médical interdit aux médecins
de révéler son identité
[Musique]
je suis assez suspicieux devant ces gens
qui peuvent voir la Vierge à 18h40
depuis 15 ans ce qu'on peut dire c'est
qu'il y a des gens qui appartiennent en
moi ils sont sur un certain registre
continue à se situer sur ce registre
qu'à partir du moment on pourrait dire
où les voies neurologiques se sont
créées en fait elles fonctionnent donc
on peut supposer que quelque part à
partir du moment où la personne s'est
mis en état d'être visionnaire où il
reproduit d'une manière quasiment
rituelle le contexte c'est-à-dire un
office religieux une foule de prions et
prions selon un certain registre le
phénomène peut se reproduire
dans l'ensemble des autres religions on
s'aperçoit que le phénomène de
l'apparition le phénomène de la
révélation est quasiment un phénomène
courant
et que c'est le contraire les
monothéistes qui les ont extrêmement
réduits je veux dire le chaman lui des
apparitions il en a pratiquement trois
ou quatre par semaine c'est normal c'est
normal c'est au contraire chez nous que
les apparitions sur les plus rares parce
que dans le monothéisme on considère
qu'il y a un fossé entre le Dieu et la
créature du coup le phénomène
d'apparition devient quand même je
dirais très très facilement suspect et
on se demande toujours si d'une certaine
manière ce n'est pas une ruse du Diable
[Musique]
à plusieurs reprises les vagues de la
région de Medjugorje a mis en doute
l'origine surnaturelle de ses
apparitions mais rien n'interdit à
infidèle de se rendre sur un lieu
d'apparition présumé même s'il n'est pas
reconnu et les frères franciscains qui
dirige la paroisse les villageois et les
voyants ont tout fait pour attirer les
pèlerins malgré les mises en garde
répétées de l'évêque c'est-à-dire on est
dans un moment où les chrétiens
finalement se sont donné le droit à
eux-mêmes de juger eux-mêmes ce qui est
vrai ce qui n'est pas vrai ce qui leur
convient ce qui leur convient pas
Jean-Paul II peut dire absolument ce
qu'il veut sur ce qu'il veut on n'écoute
pas on les évêque on ne les on ne les
écoute pas non plus
depuis quelques siècles l'Église
catholique est toujours très hésitante
avant de se prononcer sur l'origine
divine d'une apparition de la Vierge au
XXème siècle sur plus d'un millier
d'apparitions recensées l'église en a
reconnu seulement une dizaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je verrai deux motifs qui poussent des
foules à se rendre sur les lieux
d'apparition mariage
le premier motif
[Musique]
c'est une carence de l'Église catholique
l'église moneglise
ne s'est véritablement pas
présenté le dieu de la Libération
le dieu de la Résurrection d'une manière
attractive
et chaleureuse
si on va sur les lieux de pèlerinage
c'est quand même avant de voir l'aspect
pénitentiel on veut trouver une chaleur
de proximité
[Musique]
les gens cherchent Dieu alors souvent il
ne trouve pas là où ils sont ça leur
paraît vite ça leur paraît abstrait je
crois que malgré certains efforts la
liturgie reste très abstraite les
charmants aussi
pour les gens de la Vierge c'est plus
concrète un être de chair et de sang
c'est une mère
beaucoup de gens sont mal aimés ils
savent que paraît au moins ils sont
aimés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a chacun nos blessures du passé
on est tout petit on grandit puis on
traîne des blessures des événements des
situations des expériences moi ce que je
peux dire c'est que en moi ce qui
manquait c'était la présence réelle de
ma maman Marie pour
pour ouvrir mon coeur
[Musique]
j'avais plus de goût à la vie j'avais
acheté à découragé
il va pas de dépression mais je te
découragé j'avais plus de solution fait
un moment donné j'étais j'écris au
secours j'étais dans un église puis un
avant de Saint Sacrement puis je dis
Seigneur ça existe leur avec toi parce
que moi je suis capable de dire puis la
Vierge
ça me dit dans mon cœur revient me voir
à midi
[Musique]
maman Marie pour moi est très très
importante depuis quelques années après
beaucoup de place dans ma vie
j'ai toujours eu la foi mais c'est elle
qui m'a appris plus à retourner vers
l'église à retourner
plus vers ces valeurs j'avais la foi
mais c'était pas le centre de ma vie
puis malgré tout le cheminement que je
faisais
j'arrivais pas à
sentir la paix et le bonheur intérieur
on a l'impression que vous préférez la
Vierge à votre mère
parce que
parce que ma mère c'est bon à me donner
la vie
dans un sens mais c'est Seigneur qui est
passé en tout cas nous on est là pour
procréer le Seigneur et le pourri Dieu
est là pour créer
elle m'a donné la vie mais elle est
humaine son amour est pas parfait comme
le mien est pas parfait envers mes
enfants ou envers elle non plus
Marie je peux tout lui confier je peux
je fais mabandonner complètement à elle
sur ce que je peux pas faire avec ma
mère parce qu'elle est humaine chose que
mes enfants peuvent pas faire avec moi
malgré tout l'amour que j'ai pour
[Musique]
ce qui est manifeste dans la Genèse le
développement et le succès de la
croyance aux apparitions de la Vierge
puisque
historiquement elle dure depuis 1500 ans
c'est le fait que ce soit une figure
féminine qui incarne quelque chose du du
lien nécessaire que les hommes
entretiennent que les hommes du
christianisme entretiennent entre le
ciel et la terre
voir la Vierge est en quelque sorte
accéder à la manifestation du visage
humain de Dieu en quelque sorte on peut
dire que que ce visage féminin vient
adoucir
le via adoucir et en même temps montrer
quelque chose du visage de ce Dieu qui
paraît aux hommes bien inaccessibles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le Dieu
qui nous a été inculqué la plupart du
temps est un dieu masculin
et l'église qui prétend le service et
qui le sert en tant qu'il est magiste
l'Église a toujours eu ça commence très
tôt avec les pères de les pères des
premiers siècles l'Église a toujours eu
un mépris de la femme
[Musique]
la théologie savante a clairement
tranché en disant même si elle est la
mère de Dieu ce n'est quand même qu'une
femme élue effectivement qui n'est
pratiquement pas comparable à aucune
autre le miracle d'Immaculée conception
etc mais c'est une femme il est évident
que dans le sentiment populaire la
Vierge c'est une déesse
je ne l'ai pas vu mais je l'ai senti
porter je me suis sentie bercé
le temps
[Musique]
qui font beaucoup de pèlerinage ce sont
des gens qui sont asphyxiés dans leur
foi ils savent que leur foi c'est
important et puis ils sont dans un monde
où la fouette irrespirable tout par le
contre alors ils ont un petit signe de
Dieu alors il se jette là-dessus comme
quelqu'un d'affamé se jette sur un
fumier pour ramasser un morceau de pain
[Musique]
on n'a pas besoin d'extraordinaire pour
vivre sa foi
il est beaucoup plus difficile de
pratiquer la charité au jour le jour que
d'aller sur les lieux de pèlerinage
auprès des apparitions et puis d'aller à
la suite des visionnaires et pour
s'extasier
recevoir des impositions de main tomber
dans le repas de l'esprit baiser les
petits cailloux qu'on ramasse
collectionner les feuilles de l'arbre
sur lequel la Vierge est posée etc ça
c'est pas de la charité
ce sont des rituels magiques
[Musique]
il protège le pouvoir que détient la
technologie dans notre vie est-elle que
certains ont commencé à penser que ce
que les êtres humains ne peuvent voir
avec les yeux la photographie elle peut
le capter
[Musique]
cette chose étrange les gens les
pèlerins se rendent sur les lieux
d'apparition et prennent des photos il
ne voit rien mais pense que lorsqu'il
donneront leur pellicule à développer
quelque chose apparaîtra et ceci se
produit dans tous les lieux d'apparition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si nous possédions une seule photo
prouvant l'existence de la Madone
définit alors nous aurions
définitivement éliminé de l'histoire
humaine la religion chrétienne
dans un laboratoire scientifique
ce ne serait plus le pape qui aurait le
dernier mot dans le christianisme
mais serait un prix Nobel un
scientifique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'apparition est quelque part un domaine
inexplorable pour les sciences les
sciences habituelles
la science peut dire des choses sur la
sur l'apparition en tant que matière
c'est par exemple la guérison les
phénomènes matériels de la de
l'apparition elle peut dire des choses
sur les aspects psychologiques les
circonstances de l'apparition les le
compte asticologique de l'apparition
mais ne peut pas se lancer dans ce qu'on
appelle la réalité de l'apparition elle
ne peut rien dire sur la réalité de la
Vierge et des choses équivalentes là il
s'agit de domaines qui sont soit du
registre du paranormal soit du registre
de la foi
[Musique]